Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Von wegen Rasenfunk-Sommerpause. Die Diskussion rund um den Rücktritt von Mesut Özil hat auch uns so sehr beschäftigt, dass es jetzt dazu hier eine Folge gibt, mit Fatih Demireli, dem Chefredakteur vom Sokrates Magazin. Fatih, sei mir sehr herzlich gegrüßt. Hi. Ja, jetzt muss es doch eine Rasenfunk-Folge geben. Ich wollte eigentlich eine kleine Sommerpause machen. Wir haben uns gerade auch schon drüber unterhalten. Du hättest auch noch anderes zu tun gehabt, als diese Mesut Özil-Debatte irgendwie abzufedern. Aber da kam uns dann all das dazwischen. Was passiert ist im Nachgang nach der Weltmeisterschaft? Und weil das so ein großes Thema ist, dass ich glaube, dass wir da auch noch ein paar Jahre drüber sprechen, gibt es jetzt auch einen Kurzpass dazu. Und ich freue mich sehr, dass ich dich mit dabei habe. Schön, dass du Zeit hast.
Das Thema ist natürlich jetzt auf Dauer rennen und darauf freue ich mich eigentlich nicht. Das wird uns tatsächlich noch lange lange beschäftigen und wahrscheinlich mich auch noch lange beschäftigen.
Ja, das glaube ich. Und mir war es auch irgendwie wichtig, als ich drüber nachgedacht habe, mit wem würde ich gerne sprechen wollen im Rasenfunk. Jetzt habe ich mit dir einen Gast hier, der auch deutscher ist mit türkischen Wurzeln. Und normalerweise hätte ich dich ehrlich gesagt nicht angefragt, weil ich das schwierig finde, Leute in Schubladen zu stecken. Ich finde das schwierig zu sagen, hey, du hast doch eine irgendwie ganz grob vergleichbare Biografie mit der von Mesut Özil. Deswegen musst du dich doch dazu äußern. Aber du hast auch mal einen sehr guten Text geschrieben und zwar schon lange vor dem Rücktritt von Mesut Özil, in dem du auch die Frage gestellt hast, kann ich denn nicht bitte einfach nur deutscher sein? Und weil du dich damit quasi schon mal so in die Öffentlichkeit rausgewagt hast und dich dazu positioniert hast, dachte ich, okay, dann wirst du es vermutlich auch nicht als Schublade empfinden, wenn ich dich einfach mal anfrage, wollen wir über Özil sprechen. Aber wie stehst du dem gegenüber? Es ist ja irgendwie eine ein bisschen paradoxe Situation jetzt als in Deutschland lebende Mensch mit Migrationshintergrund Türkei.
Das ist tatsächlich schwierig für mich. Auch bei dem Text, den ich geschrieben habe mit dem Titel, darf ich deutscher sein, den habe ich angefangen wenige Tage nachdem das Foto aufgekommen ist. Und dann eben so die erste Welle an Kritik kam, da habe ich die ersten Zeilen geschrieben. Da habe ich gesagt, komm lass es, beende das Thema. Ich wusste dann auch selbst nicht, wo der Text hingehen soll. Und dann, als es immer heftiger wurde, immer heftiger wurde und dann die WM vorbei war, habe ich gesagt, komm, jetzt musst du den Text zu Ende schreiben und dann auch veröffentlichen. Warum habe ich mich schwergetan, das ist die Frage. Du hast recht, ich bin in München geboren, ich bin in München aufgewachsen, alles hier, das komplette Programm. Aber ich habe eben auch mal meine Wurzeln und da hatte ich ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen die Befürchtung, und die ist auch jetzt immer noch da ehrlich gesagt, der hat jetzt den gleichen Hintergrund wie der Özil, der muss den nur verteidigen. Oder der ist jetzt nicht objektiv, der kann es jetzt nur aus subjektiver Betrachtung sehen und auch kommentieren. Das mag sogar im Teilen sein, weil ich eben in gewissen Punkten auch Empathie empfinden kann, was Mesut Özil empfindet. Aber eigentlich ist es genau das, was auch der Text hier ausstieht. Ich bin Deutscher, also ich habe in die USA was anderes gemacht als Deutscher zu sein. Ich bin hier geboren, groß geworden, hatte eigentlich lange Zeit auch nur deutsche Freunde, sehr geile türkische Freunde. Und warum soll ich mir dann selbst dieses Recht abnehmen, die Sache nicht objektiv zu sehen? Bis auf den Sichtpunkt, dass ich Empathie empfinden kann, kann ich das objektiv sehen. Und wie sehe ich die Sache? Und da fängt es auch schon an. Ich war bei kurz nach dem Foto, war ich genauso wie bei allen anderen, dass ich das nicht verstanden habe, warum er dieses Foto macht. Aber, und dann kommt natürlich auch das Hintergrundwissen, dass ich auch da hatte, das ist auch nicht das erste Foto. Also die Verbindung Mesut Özil, Recep Tayyip Erdogan, die ist halt einfach auch schon länger da. Die ist jetzt nicht da entstanden, nicht zu dem Steuern entstanden. Bei Ilkay Gündoğan war es schon so, das muss man sagen, aber bei Mesut Özil war es nicht zum ersten Mal, deswegen hat es mich überrascht. Aber natürlich dann, Zeitpunkt des Fotos, Veröffentlichungen und so weiter, das hat mich dann schon abgewundert, warum macht er das jetzt? Er ist ja auch jetzt nicht jemand, der alleine unterwegs ist. Du weißt, das ist ja auch in den letzten Tagen auch das Thema gewesen. Er hat einen großen Beraterstab, er hat eine Agentur, alles drum und dran. Die werden ihm doch gesagt haben, also er würde es ja nicht vereinigt haben, wenn er dort war. Und das müssen sie mir doch gesagt haben, dass das Folgen haben wird. Und das hat mich gewundert, hat mich überrascht. Und ich habe dann auch selbst Kritik geübt, ob es öffentlich ist oder unter meinem Freundespreis, was auch immer, habe ich Kritik geübt. Aber, und dann ging es, ja, in einem Teil in der Medienlandschaft, auch in der Gesellschaft, und da zähle ich heute eben auch die sozialen Medien einfach komplett dazu, die Art und Weise, wie dieses Thema dann angefasst wurde, das fand ich dann krass. Also das hatte dann für mich keine Verhältnismäßigkeit mehr. Das ist für mich teilweise ins systematische Smobbing übergeschnappt, und an dem Punkt ist es gefährlich, und an dem Punkt habe ich dann auch irgendwann angefangen, das habe ich aufgeschrieben, glaube ich, bei meinem Twitter-Channel, habe ich angefangen, mich so ein bisschen auf Tim Özil umzuschlagen, weil ich es nicht mehr einfach verhältnismäßig fand. Man darf ihn kritisieren dafür, dass er dieses Treffen kam und dann dieses Foto entstanden ist, auch zu dem Zeitpunkt vor allem. Konstruktiv war die Kritik dann eigentlich nicht mehr. Zumindest war die konzeptive Kritik, die aufkam, war dann nicht mehr zu sehen, einen ganzen Walz von, ja, polemischer und sehr harscher Kritik.
Das ganze Ding ist ganz schön eskaliert in einer Art und Weise, wie ich es mir auch nicht vorstellen könnte. Deshalb bin ich auch froh, jemanden dabei zu haben, der zumindest diese Lebenssituation vielleicht nachempfinden kann. Deswegen habe ich eben quasi dich aus der Schublade der Leute rausgeholt, die ich kenne, von denen ich weiß, sie haben auch einen Migrationshintergrund, aber sind in Deutschland sozialisiert worden. Und deswegen war ich froh, dass du dir die Zeit hier nimmst im Rasenfunk, weil ich einfach als sehr unangenehmen Teil dieser Debatte empfinde, dass sich auch ganz viele über eine Lebenswelt äußern, von der ich sage, wenn man diesen Migrationshintergrund nicht hat, dann kann man sich eigentlich nicht vorstellen, meiner Meinung nach, wie das sein muss. Ich kann es mir wirklich nicht vorstellen. Ich habe deutsche Wurzeln, keine Ahnung, wie viele Generationen meiner Familie hier aus Deutschland kommen. Irgendwann gab es wahrscheinlich auch mal Einwanderungen in meine... Aber ich habe nur meinen deutschen Bezugsrahmen, deswegen kann ich es mir einfach nicht vorstellen. Und ich finde, dass es eines der Dinge, was diese Debatte für mich etwas anstrengend macht, ist, dass sich viele Leute äußern, von denen ich sagen würde, wir interpretieren ja wahnsinnig viel in ein Foto. Und wir interpretieren wahnsinnig viel aus Zeilen heraus, die Mesut Özil gesagt hat, die hat dann Reinhard Grindel gesagt hat, die Oliver Bierhoff gesagt haben. Und das alles vor einem beschränkten Erfahrungshorizont. Und das finde ich etwas schwierig.
Also, es ist tatsächlich so, dass man sich das... Dass man das...
Es ist keine Schwarz-Weiß-Debatte. Und es ist auch keine Debatte. Du hast jetzt gesagt, Team Özil, da bin ich kurz ein bisschen zusammengezückt, weil ich glaube, in dieser Debatte kann man in gar keinem Team mehr sein, weil jeder Seite... Ja, doch, es gibt Seiten in der Debatte, kann man glaube ich sagen. Also, du kannst sowohl Mesut Özil als auch dem DFB, als auch den Medien, als auch den Mitspielern von Özil, als auch der Öffentlichkeit, den Fans, den Zuschauern, den Deutschen... An jedem kannst du Kritik festmachen. Es ist so viel kaputt gegangen, so viel zu Bruch gegangen in dieser Diskussion. Es gibt eigentlich kaum die Möglichkeit zu sagen, wenn man sich wirklich alle Argumente zu Gemüte führt, zu sagen, oh, diese eine Seite hat sich jetzt nur korrekt verhalten. Nein, das ist nicht so. Es ist eine typische Debatte. Das ist wie ein gordischer Knoten, bei dem du dich gefragt hast, also, wenn ein Kind auf dem Spielplatz sagt, kannst du mir mal den Knoten aus der Schleife machen? Und du guckst dir das Ding an, denkst dir, wie hast du das denn um Himmels willen hinbekommen? Du warst doch nur auf der Rutsche. Und so ein bisschen ist diese Debatte. Was wir jetzt nicht machen wollen, Fatih, ist, wir wollen das jetzt nicht von vorne bis hinten aufrollen. Und ich möchte auch ungern eine Debatte nur noch mal auch im Rasenfunk führen, wie sie gerade schon alle Orten geführt wird. Also die wichtigen Argumente noch mal rausgraben, die Chronologie der Ereignisse und so weiter. Was ich dagegen mit dir machen wollen würde, ist, ich würde dir jetzt gerne ein paar Fragen stellen, die meiner Meinung nach in der Diskussion komischerweise ein bisschen untergehen, die gar nicht so häufig beantwortet werden. Und das Ganze soll dann eher, ich würde sagen, eine Art Impulsgeber sein für die Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen, die sowieso schon ganz viel zu dem Thema wissen, die vermutlich auch eine eigene Haltung haben. Und da würde ich jetzt gerne einfach so in verschiedene Richtungen kleine Fragennadelstiche setzen. Ich bin sehr gespannt auf deine Antworten. Und dann ist es vielleicht ein Mehrwert für die Leute da draußen und nicht einfach nur die Sendung 2005, 2006, 2007 zu diesem ganzen Özil-Sachverhalt. Lass mich mal mit einer etwas, ja, vielleicht dann auch schon provozierenden Frage loslegen, die aber meiner Meinung nach gar nicht so häufig beantwortet würde. Welche Argumente gab es denn eigentlich aus Sicht von Mesut Özil, die dafür sprachen, das Foto mit Erdogan zu machen?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich glaube, das ist, die Frage stellen sich ja auch viele. Die Frage wird eigentlich nicht schnell. Es heißt dann immer, ja, gut, Erdogan, hier jetzt ist die Wahl. Für jemanden mit türkischen Wurzeln macht es ja auch Sinn, sich vielleicht mit dem zu zeigen und dann kann man das Foto machen, fertig bringen. Ich glaube, man sollte sich das nicht so einfach machen. Man muss da, glaube ich, so ein bisschen auch in die Tiefe gehen, was Mesut Özil für einen Lebenslauf hat. Man muss sehen, was überhaupt Türken in Deutschland, in Deutschland lebende Türken oder türkische Migrationshintergrund für einen Weg gezeichnet haben. Und vielleicht da nach den Gründen suchen, warum man so ein Foto macht. Zum einen ist es so, dass Erdogan, das weiß man ja auch jetzt inzwischen von den drei Jungs, die da bei ihm waren, gerne die Gegenwart von Fußballern suchen. Und das ist bei weitem dann auch nicht nur Mesut Özil und Elkay Gündoğan und Cenk Tuzun, der auch auf dem Foto war. In der Türkei sind da noch mal ein paar mehr. Also so ein Arda Turan zum Beispiel, so ein Burakil Masz zum Beispiel, das sind schon wieder auch mit den größten Namen des türkischen Fußballs. Sie zeigen sich auch gerne mit ihm, sind gerne auf Einladungen, Erdogan. Es sucht gerne ein Fußballumfeld, zum Beispiel der Basak Ceylin, einer der besten Mannschaften der letzten Jahre in der Super League. Er ist eigentlich mehr oder weniger Gründungsvater und hat in den neuen Stadien, was sie gemacht haben, aufgebaut. Das erste Tor geschossen, hat in der Hetrick gemacht, natürlich war der Torwart da, unhaltbare Schüsse abgefangen. Aber auch, weil er selbst einst wohl so talentiert war, eine Karriere als Fußballer zu starten, hat er dann nicht gemacht und ist dann lieber Politiker geworden. Also er sucht dann schon sehr, sehr offensiv die Umgebung Fußball. Natürlich dann auch irgendwann, weil es einfach populär ist. Also es ist einfach so, dass Fußball in der Tür keine komplett andere Bedeutung hat. Das weiß man ja inzwischen, dass es nicht nur einfach der Sport ist oder die schönste Nebensache der Welt. Das ist für viele Türken die wichtigste Sache der Welt. Und das weiß eben auch Erdogan. Und was auch dazu kommt, ist dann einfach, dass er, was man hier im Zwanili versteht, immer noch eine sehr, sehr große Beliebtheit genießt. Und natürlich von seiner Politik, das muss ich auch sagen. Und im Zuge dessen, das eben, ich habe gerade gesagt die Adaturan, das ist dann schon so, dass sich dann auch so eine kleine Familie entwickelt. Also gerade beim Fußball entwickelt sich eine kleine Familie von Fußballern, die sehr bekannt sind. Und das sind nämlich nur Fußballer, das sind auch andere Figuren aus TV, auf Shows, Entertainment. Und irgendwann ist auch Mesut Özil da reingerutscht. Irgendwann hat er diese Leute gekannt. Irgendwann waren sie gemeinsam im Urlaub. Irgendwann waren sie gemeinsam auf irgendwelchen Phönäen. Sie haben ihn in Madrid besucht. Sie haben ihn in London besucht. Sie waren auf irgendwelche Schalkeaktionen gemeinsam unterwegs. Und irgendwann heißt es dann, hey, komm, lass uns doch mal zum Erdogan gehen. Der fröhst wieder auch mal vor, wenn wir da hingehen. Und ich glaube, an dem Punkt ist es dann tatsächlich schwierig, tatsächlich schwierig abzulehnen. Zu sagen, nee, mach mal, ich geh da jetzt nicht hin. Zumal ich ja auch gerade Leute habe, dass die Abredung da nicht so groß ist. Und dann macht man das und dann bist du einmal da und dann bist du nochmal da. Und irgendwann hat sich das eingespielt. Der Fehler beginnt dann eigentlich vielleicht schon beim ersten Treffen. Wenn du das erste nicht machst, dann müssen die weiteren nicht folgen. Aber du bist irgendwann in diesem Kreis von Leuten drin, die ständig seine Umgebung suchen. Und ich glaube nicht, dass das Mesut jetzt, ich glaube, das war einfach dann so eine Gewohnheit inzwischen, dass er gar nicht so groß selbst ablegen konnte, ob es jetzt okay ist, dass ich jetzt so kurz vor der WM und gerade kurz vor der Wahl dahingehe, nicht dass die Leute das jetzt irgendwie falsch verstehen. Ich glaube, da war einfach schon viel zu viel Gewohnheit drin.
Also das ist ja nichts Neues, dass sich Politiker gerne in der Gegenwart von Fußballern zeigen. Und auch bei Erdogan hat man das schon häufiger beobachten können. Es gibt ja auch schon vor der WM 2014 gab es schon ein Foto zwischen Erdogan und Mesut Özil. Jetzt hat sich ja in dieser Zeit politisch auch einiges getan. Und die Frage, die ein bisschen gestellt wird, ist, so wie du das beschreibst, das kann man alles nachvollziehen und man kann auch ein bisschen Naivität unterstellen oder kann sagen, vielleicht war sich der Dimension dieses Fotos auch nicht bewusst. Kann man denn dem Politiker Erdogan, von dem Menschen Erdogan, der sich gerne mit Fußballern umgibt, darf man die voneinander trennen und darf auch Mesut Özil da sagen, ich habe mich quasi in einem, sagen wir mal, unpolitischen Kontext mit ihm getroffen, ich wollte nur Respekt erweisen meiner Wurze und meiner Wurzeln. Und da ist eben Erdogan gerade der gewählte Präsident.
Also aus unserer Perspektive darf man es nicht trennen, natürlich nicht. Aber ich kenne ihn nicht persönlich. Ich habe ihn vorher nicht zehnmal getroffen. Deswegen kann ich die Deklarenzierung auch machen. Für jemanden wie Mesut Özil, oder egal auch wer, es ist nicht immer Özil, egal wer ihn getroffen hat, hat ihn letztes Jahr zum ersten Mal getroffen als Erdogan. Das ist, was er jetzt nicht, jemand der gefährliche Politik betreibt. Er hat ihn fast vor 2010, glaube ich, das erste Treffen. Und da war Erdogan noch weit nicht die Figur, die er heute ist. Und wenn du dich seitdem mit ihm ständig triffst, viel Austausch hast, und der Austausch ist übrigens auch nicht nur, sich da mal zu treffen, sondern auch telefonischer Kontakt ist auch immer wieder da. Ich weiß, dass Erdogan auch viel mit Fußballern telefoniert. Und dann geht es einfach nicht nur darum zu sagen, ja, komm, lass uns mal ein Foto machen, weil ich habe gleich eine Wahl. Geburte eines Kindes, Verletzungen, Tor. Da kommt dann auch mal nach dem Spiel oder eben nach seiner Geburt ein Anruf. Und sagt, hallo, hier ist Receptheit Erdogan und viel Glück zu deinem Kind. Und das sind vor allem Anrufe, die nicht öffentlich werden. Das weiß ich ja eben aus diesem Kreise. Und das hinterlässt Eindruck. Das muss man einfach sagen. Ob das jetzt dann von Erdogan auch so gewollt ist, ob das so geplant ist, dass er es auch nicht öffentlich macht und so. Das weiß ich nicht. Das wäre jetzt eine Mutmaßung. Aber diese Verbindung wurde einfach in den letzten Jahren aufgebaut. Und dass man dann auch eine Emotionalität aufbaut und dann in einer Phase, in der Erdogan in der breiten Öffentlichkeit, in der Welt inzwischen ein schwieriges Standing hat, dann sind sie einfach auch zu subjektiv. Das hätte natürlich Haltung, aber wenn sie sagen, schau mal, vor ein paar Jahren war alles noch gut, es hat auch deine Politik, dann hast du auch das Land, in dem ich Fußball spiele, nicht projialisiert alle Nazis genannt. Aber das machst du inzwischen, jetzt möchte ich dich deswegen nicht mehr treffen. Das soll erstmal einer machen. Das ist, glaube ich, selbst zu fordern, das ist gut, das ist okay, das ist legitim, aber dann die Ausführung ist dann nicht so einfach, vor allem, wenn man in so einem Kreis ist. Und von daher glaube ich, dass wir das uns selbst zu einfach machen. Ich habe auch gesagt, komm, sage nicht von dem los, das ist jetzt nicht mehr der Typ, den du damals gekannt hast, aber die Umsetzung ist dann tatsächlich nicht einfach. Zumal, und dann hat Mesut Recht, er hat da Familie, sie lebt da, sie möchte da auch leben und da ist aber schon ein bisschen Angst auch da, dass man den ganzen so ein bisschen erschwert.
Ja, also das ist ja auch der Grund, warum wahrscheinlich die Entrüstung so groß war, dass der Erdogan von 2014 nicht mehr der Erdogan von 2018 ist. Dazwischen liegt eine wesentliche Zuspitzung der Machtverhältnisse in der Türkei, die Entrechtlichung, hätte ich es fast jetzt bezeichnet, von Teilen der Bevölkerung. Es sitzen politische Gegner, Journalisten sitzen in Haft. Es gibt viele Dinge, die man am Politiker Erdogan kritisieren kann. Und da hätte auch im Nachhinein Mesut Özil relativ einfach, auch wenn es diese ganzen Widerstände gibt und Gegenargumente, die du gerade genannt hast, er hätte sich auch davon distanzieren können und vielleicht auch sollen. Aber die Frage, die ich mir gestellt habe, also wie gesagt liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, es geht jetzt nicht darum, dass wir hier nur unsere Meinung runterbeten, sondern ich möchte ein paar Impulse setzen jetzt mit einigen Fragen, die nicht so gestellt werden. Die Frage, die ich mir schon eine Weile jetzt gestellt habe ist, warum muss sich eigentlich jemand oder soll sich jemand in Deutschland für seine Meinung entschuldigen in einem Land der Meinungsfreiheit? Müssten wir es nicht eigentlich auch aushalten, wenn Mesut Özil jetzt gesagt hätte, es tut mir leid, ich finde alles an Erdogan super, vielleicht sogar auch seine Politik? Ich sage nicht, wir müssen es gut finden, aber wir müssen es doch aushalten können eigentlich.
Also er hat es nicht gesagt, aber in dem Moment, in dem er sich nicht entschuldigt, ist er zumindest neutral. Also das muss man ja schon zustande stehen lassen. Also er hat sich nicht jetzt von der Politik irgendwie losgesagt oder...
Er hat sich nicht distanziert und hätte genügend Möglichkeiten gehabt.
Genau, er hat sich nicht distanziert. Das suggeriert ja dann schon, dass er das zumindest nicht... Also wahrscheinlich nicht, dass er sich die Politik nicht so schlimm findet. Wobei ich mir ehrlich gesagt auch nicht sicher bin, ob Mesut Özil das wirklich auch so einschätzen kann. Ob er das wirklich so weiß, für welche Politik Erdogan steht.
Ich hoffe, dass er sich im Nachgang des Fotos dann irgendwann mal damit auseinandergesetzt hat, dass er das jetzt haben wird, spätestens.
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich würde mich nicht wundern, wenn es nicht so wäre. Ich muss ganz offen sagen. Weil wir beschäftigen uns mit dem Thema. Viele meiner türkischen Freunde beschäftigen sich damit, aber es ist verblüffend zu sehen, wie viele Leute es nicht tun. Das tut mir manchmal ein bisschen weh. Aber Mesut Özil hat sich nicht entschuldigt, weil er, glaube ich, aus seiner Warte es auch so sieht, dass er sich nicht entschuldigen muss. Für ihn ist es völlig normal, dieses Foto gemacht zu haben. Er sieht es, glaube ich, immer noch nicht als Fehler. Er sieht es immer noch nicht auch nicht als zeitlichen Fehler. Für ihn ist es einfach so, ich habe dieses Foto gemacht, weil ich der Überzeugung war. Es war für ihn ein Treffen mit einem Freund, mit einem Bekannten. Und dafür müssen wir nicht entschuldigen. Ich glaube, das ist sein Standpunkt. Wir dürfen Mesut Özil dafür kritisieren. Aber wir dürfen ihm seine Meinung nicht diktieren. Ich darf Mesut Özil nicht gut finden. Du darfst ihn nicht gut finden. Wir finden ihn auch nicht gut. Aber es ist leider das Recht von Mesut Özil, dass er mit ihm sympathisiert. Das ist sein Recht.
Wir können doch nicht sagen, dass wenn jemand sich in der Nationalmannschaft zur AfD bekennen würde, nehmen wir mal das andere Extrem, dann würden wir das auch nicht gut finden. Es geht jetzt auch nicht um unsere persönliche Haltung. Aber wir müssten es doch aushalten. Wir können doch nicht sagen, deshalb darf derjenige nicht mehr in der Nationalmannschaft mitspielen. Was ist dann das nächste? Dürfen dann auch Beamte nicht mehr sich öffentlich zu bestimmten Positionen bekennen, die eine Mehrheit nicht gut findet? Das ist das Groteske an dieser ganzen Debatte, wie ich finde. Wir reden über einen Machthaber, der diktatorische Züge hat, der ein System etabliert hat, in dem die Meinungsfreiheit wesentlich beschränkt wird. Und gleichzeitig gestehen wir diese Meinungsfreiheit in dieser sehr aufgeheizten Debatte aber dann auch selbst gar nicht so wirklich zu. Das tut weh, aber man muss es aushalten, wenn Leute Erdogan gut finden und muss mit denen in die Diskussion vielleicht gehen.
Es ist so, ob es AfD oder Erdogan ist. Man darf aus persönlicher Meinung nach sagen, für mich darf er der Nationalmannschaft nicht mehr spielen. Das darf man glaube ich schon sagen. Aber man darf dann Mesut Özil nicht das Recht absprechen, deutscher zu sein oder zu sagen, wir dürfen weiter in Deutschland leben. Dieses Recht haben wir nicht. Man kann vielleicht fordern, weil die Nationalmannschaft eine gewisse Vorbildfunktion hat, dass sie für etwas steht und dass man deswegen einfordert, egal ob es ein Spieler ist, Spieler A, der sich für die AfD zu AfD bekennt oder B, zu Erdogan bekennt oder egal was auch immer, dass man dann sagen kann, der darf nicht für die Nationalmannschaft spielen. Das fordere ich jetzt an, das ist okay, das ist legitim. Aber man darf diesen Spielern oder dieser Person nicht absprechen, dass sie jetzt weiter in Deutschland leben sollen. Das geht mir deutlich zu weit. Das hatte dann für mich tatsächlich Züge vom systematischen Mobbing, was betrieben wurde. Und das sehe ich dann genauso. Wo ist dann die Meinungsfreiheit? Wie geht es dann weiter? Was ist dann das nächste? Und wo fängt man an, wenn jetzt Spieler mit ungarischen Wurzeln kommen und sagen, ich finde den Orban gut? Ja, das ist ein Premierminister des EU-Landes. Muss man den dann auch aus Deutschland verweisen und sagen, ja, darfst du in der Nationalmannschaft gehen? Wo ist die Grenze? Wann darf man Fremdmann sein und wann darf man nicht Fremdmann sein? Muss man jetzt alle rausschmeißen, weil sie Spieler von Rainer Drindl sind, weil er vor Jahren hier das Multikulti-Thema in Deutschland gut geredet hat. Also wo ist die Grenze? Ich weiß nicht, wo die Grenze ist. Das ist eine gefährliche Debatte. Man darf diese Grenzen nicht zu sehr ausdoten, sonst haben wir in Deutschland auch das Problem, dass wir über Meinungsfreiheit sprechen müssen.
Man kann das natürlich erklären, gerade die Art und Weise, wie die Nationalmannschaft zu einem Paradebeispiel für Integration aufgebaut wurde. Umso härter trifft es sie natürlich, wenn du dann anhand einer solchen Sache, wie dieser Mesut Özil, des Fotos und des Verhaltens danach dann siehst, so gut hat die Integration ja dann nicht geklappt. Also man kann das alles erklären, warum das so kommt. Aber die eigentlich interessante Frage ist doch, warum sind denn so viele in Deutschland lebende Türken überhaupt Erdogan-Befürwörter? Also wenn wir unser Wertesystem, die Grundrechte, die Art und Weise, wie Deutschland sein Recht ausübt und Freiheiten gewährt im Einzelnen, das widerspricht da schon in ganz, ganz großen Teilen dem, was Erdogan in der Türkei macht. Kannst du mir das erklären? Warum gibt es so viele Erdogan-Fans unter deutschstämmigen Türken?
Das ist tatsächlich kein einfaches Thema. Ich kann das jetzt auch, was ich jetzt versuche zu erklären, ist auch keine pauschale Erklärung dafür, warum Erdogan so beliebt ist. Ich kann aber aus meinen Erfahrungen auch von Familienmitgliedern, von Freunden, von Bekannten, die ihn wählen und ich dann auch versuchen nachzuvollziehen, warum sie ihn wählen und auch in der Türkei wählen, nicht nur in Deutschland wählen, die Gründe sind da nicht sehr weit auseinander, zu erklären, warum das so ist. Aber wie gesagt, keine pauschale Erklärung. Vielleicht müssen auch Menschen auch sagen, die sagen, cool, die kreaturische Türke mag ich vielleicht auch, das kann auch sein. Aber ich versuche es mal zu erklären. Ja, das ist so, dass das viele Türken, eigentlich mag ich diesen Ausdruck nicht, aber ich hoffe, dass das auch jetzt nicht falsch gestanden wird. Es gibt da schon so einen kleinen Minderwertigkeitskomplex, der sich in der jungen, in der jungen, in der jungenale Geschichte eingebürgert hat. Das hat viel damit zu tun, dass die Türkei sich immer so ein bisschen umgerechnet hat. Ich bin nicht derjenige, der das nicht behandelt gefühlt hat. Wenn man es konkret auch mal nehmen will, EU-Beitrittsgründe hat seit 100 Jahren nie so richtig ernst genommen, nie eigentlich mit am Tisch der großen Nationen gesessen ist. Und das hat sich dann eingewirkt. Der Westen will uns nichts Gutes. Der Westen mögen uns nicht. Der Westen will nur, dass es uns nicht gut geht. Dieses Gefühl hat sich in vielen Jahren, in vielen Jahrzehnten eingenistet bei vielen Menschen. Und dann sucht man immer noch eine Figur, die diesen Leuten, die vermeintlich dir das Böse wollen, die Stirn bieten. Erdogan ist ein hervorragender, vorzüglicher Redner. Er kann tatsächlich einen Menschen treffen mit seiner Art und Weise, wie er spricht, mit seiner Stimme, mit seiner Art und Weise. Und er hat einfach, das ist einfach, das ist Fakt, er hat den meisten die Stirn geboten, in einer sehr deutlichen Art und Weise. Und für Menschen, die eben so ein Komplex entwickelt haben, die so ein Gefühl entwickelt haben, wurde er zu einer Vaterfigur. Und das hat unabhängig von seiner Politik, für große Sympathien, für große Zuleidung gesorgt. Und was eben auch in der türkischen Kultur, da versuche ich jetzt auch nicht so pauschal zu sein, aber es ist einfach so, in der türkischen Kultur hat einfach die Vaterfigur eine ganz, ganz besondere, wichtige Rolle. Der Vater ist einfach eine wichtige Figur. Der Vater ist der Beschützer der Familie. Der Vater ist das Oberhaupt, das über die Tapeten zu Hause entscheidet. Ist natürlich nicht so, aber so gefühlt. Es ist so. Und jemand, der eben die Stirn bietet. Und man muss sich auch mal dann zu Mütte führen, vielleicht überlegen, in der türkischen Öffentlichkeit, wer in der Gesellschaft, wer sind die Heldenfiguren? Wer sind die Anführer? Fatih Terim ist eine große Figur der Türkei, der Kena. Er ist auch jemand, der niemals zurücksteckt und sagt, Leute, wir sind nicht klein. Wir sind stark, wir sind groß. Und durch diese ganzen Läden hat er damals gerade das Leid zum UEFA-Pokalsieger gemacht, zum Supercup-Sieger gemacht, Champions League-Erfolge. Die gab es wohl alle nicht. Und das hat er immer durch eine Art und Weise gemacht. Hey, Fatih Figur, ich bin hier, ich bin euer Anführer. Wir sind auch genauso stark wie der Westen. Wir haben kein schlechteres Blut, wir haben keine schlechten Knochen. Wir können das auch. Und die Scherzfiguren, die Serien, die am meisten geguckt werden, die Soaps, die am meisten geguckt werden, da ist immer eine Figur, die irgendjemandem die Stirn bietet und dem kleinen Mann hilft. Erdogan ist eben auch diese Figur. Unabhängig von der Politik, die er betreibt, unabhängig davon, ob er jetzt Menschenlechte missachtet oder nicht, diese Figur, seine Art und Weise, wie er spricht, wie er auf die Menschen zugeht, mit welchen Argumenten er gegen Menschen übertritt, das hat viele Menschen überzeugt. Und dann kommen jetzt hier die Türken in Deutschland, die diesen Komplex eigentlich doppelt haben. Weil sie denken sich dann, wir sind hier, und wir werden auch nicht akzeptiert. Das hört sich jetzt drastisch an, ich mache es auch absichtlich so. Wir sind nicht Menschen erster Klasse. Und dann kommt ein Typ, der auch nach Deutschland kommt und sagt, hey Leute, ich bin da. Wenn die Deutschen euch nichts wollen, bin ich da. Ich werde euch nicht allein lassen. Und wenn du dann so etwas hörst und es nicht differenzieren kannst, was eigentlich jetzt Politik ist und was Mensch ist, dann entwickle ich es in ein Partien.
Oder vielleicht ist es den Leuten auch tatsächlich egal. Vielleicht müssen wir da nicht jedem Deutschen mit türkischem Migrationshintergrund unterstellen, dass er nicht differenziert genug wäre, die Politik Erdogans zu erkennen. Sondern das eine wiegt nicht das andere auf. Sondern man findet sich da wieder. Und ich finde, die interessante Anschlussfrage daran ist doch, wenn man das, was du jetzt erzählt hast, nimmt und gleichzeitig eben dem gegenüber stellt, in welchem Wertesystem Deutschland lebt, warum wird denn nicht diskutiert, was hat dann eigentlich die deutsche Gesellschaft zusammen mit den Deutschen mit türkischem Migrationshintergrund, welche Fehler sind da passiert, dass sich dieses Wertesystem offenbar nicht so weit deckt, dass man dann eben nicht so jemanden wie Erdogan in seiner Rolle von seiner Politik trennt. Das ist doch eigentlich die interessanteste Frage. Und wenn du etwas sagst von Minderwertigkeitskomplexen, von Geringschätzung, das hat ja auch Mesut Özil in seinem Statement angesprochen, dann sind wir doch sehr schnell bei Dingen, wo man sagen kann, ja, also da bekommt vielleicht auch Deutschland eine... Quittung ist jetzt ein bisschen zu hart formuliert, aber es wird gerade an einem Fall sehr sichtbar, dass die Integration von Deutschen mit Migrationshintergrund vielleicht eben nicht so töfte und super verlaufen ist, von beiden Seiten, wie man bisher dachte. Und warum wird darüber nicht diskutiert und vor allem daraus dann abgeleitet, okay, wie können wir es denn besser machen? Denn das ist doch das eigentlich Wichtigere. Das eigentlich Wichtige ist doch nicht ein Foto mit einem Machthaber. Das Interessante ist doch eigentlich das Dahinterstehende und das, warum Millionen in Deutschland lebende Deutsche mit türkischen Wurzeln, ich habe es übrigens vorhin einmal kurz genau verdreht, deutschstämmige Türken, das war natürlich Quatsch. Also seht es mir bitte nach, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Okay, sehr gut, dass du es schaffst, auch noch in so einer Sendung einen Witz zu machen. Aber das ist doch das eigentlich Interessante. Und warum können wir denn nicht darüber diskutieren, auch wenn diese Diskussion, glaube ich, wehtut? Denn da gab es vermutlich Verfehlungen auf allen Seiten. Aber darum sollte es doch eigentlich gehen. Was ist da in der Integration schiefgelaufen? Und wie kann man es vor allem verbessern, sodass wir sagen, irgendwann wird es so sein, dass jeder Deutsche oder hoffentlich zumindest die Mehrheit der Deutschen, die hier lebt, mit Migrationshintergrund, sich mit dem Wertesystem Deutschlands so identifiziert, dass es das eben dann nicht in einzelnen Fällen insofern über Bord wirft, dass andere Argumente da dann wichtiger wären? Und diese Minderwertigkeitskomplexe, die du ansprichst, da muss man nicht arg viel Literatur über die Türkei und die Geschichte des Landes lesen, um genau dieses Gefühl sehr früh beschrieben zu finden. Vielleicht könnten wir auch einfach den Deutschen mit Migrationshintergrund dieses Minderwertigkeitsgefühl versuchen zu nehmen, wenn sie es denn haben?
Ich glaube, ich würde jetzt auch gar nicht alles so negativ sehen. Ich glaube schon, dass in den letzten Jahren zumindest viel, viel versucht wurde, in die Richtung sich zu wehren. Und ich glaube auch, dass Mesut Özil in der ganzen Integrationsdebatte eine wichtige Figur eingenommen hat. Ich finde, dass Mesut Özil das größte Integrationsprojekt Deutschlands war. Das leider übrigens gescheitert ist und das macht es gerade ein bisschen schwierig, gerade in dieser politischen Atmosphäre, in der wir gerade in Deutschland stecken, macht es ein bisschen schwierig. Ich glaube schon, dass viel unternommen wurde. Aber was ich sagen muss, so die vollendete, vollendete Glaubwürdigkeit ist nicht da. Es sind bei weitem auch nicht nur die Leute, die diesen Komplex haben, die auch hier gut integriert sind, die hier in der Gesellschaft ihren Platz angenommen haben. Eigentlich, so wie ich eigentlich auch hier leben, da gibt es auch schon viele Menschen, die sagen, ich bin ja akzeptiert, ich bin hier ein Teil der Gesellschaft, aber bis ich einen Fehler mache.
Ja, oder bist du etwas willst von der Gesellschaft? Es ist genügend nachgewiesen durch Studien und entsprechende Zeitungsartikel mit Selbstversuchen, dass du, wenn du ein Mensch mit Migrationshintergrund bist, und es ist erkennbar an deinem Äußerlichen, an deinem Namen, ist es schwieriger, für dich einen Job zu bekommen, es ist schwieriger, eine Wohnung zu bekommen und, und, und.
Definitiv, man sollte vielleicht mal in den verschiedenen Städten, in die Verwaltungsverleihung, in die Sozialämter gehen, und da in die Ausländerwörter mal gehen. Und dann sich mal über etwas unterhalten, was dein gutes Recht ist. Zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, eine Verlängerung von einem Aufenthaltszyklen, obwohl du hier geboren und aufgewachsen bist. Die Art und Weise, wie die Mitarbeiter da mit einem reden, sind teilweise schon sehr, sehr grenzwertig, muss ich sagen. Also das ist nicht so einfach. Ich sehe aus eigener Perspektive nur einen Erfahrungswert. Vielleicht ist es auch wirklich jedes Mal Zufall. Jedes Mal ist es Zufall. Das kann völlig sein, aber man weiß, dass ich relativ viel reise, relativ viel fliege. Und immer wenn ich dann aus Istanbul zurückkomme, was ich dann auch als empfinde, dass es überhaupt so ist, stehen immer ein paar Zollbeamte kurz, bevor man den Flughafen verlassen darf. Und warum auch immer bin ich in neun von zehn Zeilen, werde ich rausgezogen. Einfach so. Ich werde rausgezogen, und dann ist mein Gepäck mal kontrolliert. Es kann sein, dass es jedes Mal Zufall ist, dass ich gerade ausgerechnet rausgezogen werde.
Aber es fühlt sich irgendwann für dich nicht mehr als Zufall an.
Genau, genau, darum geht es. Ich leite jetzt nicht daraus, dass ich in dem Land nicht akzeptiert werde. Ich komme auch danach zwei Minuten raus, aber warum werde ich jedes Mal rausgezogen? Also, oder wenn ich jetzt meine Frau wohne und sie lebt in Wien, ich fahre mit dem Zug relativ häufig nach Wien und in Salzburg, nach Bad Rüttgen, nach Deutschland, da gibt es ein paar Stichprobenkontrollen, Ausweise, ja, dann rate mal, wer da auch dabei ist. Also, das ist halt immer, ich sage, ich möchte da nicht herausleiten, dass ich das hier nicht akzeptiert werde, aber es ist dann schon so, dass du im Alltag gewisse Erfahrungen machst, die dir im Unterbewusstsein dieses Gefühl geben, stopp. Also, du bist dann nicht bei 100 Prozent. Und das habe ich ja in meinem Blog hier auch nochmal geschrieben. Also, es ist dann, da kommt nochmal so ein Gespräch zustande, ja, wo kommst du jetzt eigentlich her? Ja, aus München? Ja, nee, ich meine ja, München aus, nee, nee, wo kommen deine Eltern? Ja, und so weiter. Und das wirst du aber auch nicht rauskriegen, weil du kannst nicht jeden Menschen da kontrollieren und sagen so, ja, wir kennen die alle, aber was man, glaube ich, schon machen kann, ist, dass man jetzt versucht, in der aufgeheizten politischen Debatte, die dann aufkommt, da muss einfach jetzt mal vom Gas runter. Also es nimmt einen gefährlichen Zug anfänglich. Diese Flüchtlingsdebatte hat das Ganze nochmal aufgeheizt. Und ich hatte, als diese Flüchtlingsdebatte losging vor ein paar Jahren, da hatte ich das Gefühl, als viele Flüchtlinge zu uns kamen nach Deutschland, man auch gesehen hat, welche Probleme es da gibt, in die Gesellschaft zu integrieren, hatte ich das Gefühl, man hat sich auch ein paar Gespräche gefühlt, dass viele gemerkt haben, wie gut die Typen integriert sind. Dass man eigentlich gar keine großen Maßnahmen treffen muss. Dass wir eigentlich schon auf einem sehr, sehr guten Level sind. Nachdem neue Leute dazugekommen sind, die eben nicht gut integriert waren und auch nicht einfach zu integrieren waren, hatte ich schon das Gefühl, ey, seht her, wir haben das geschafft eigentlich. Wir leben in der Gesellschaft, wir sind integriert, aber die letzten Jahre durch die aufgeheizte Debatte, und ich glaube, Özil hätte dieses Foto vor ein paar Jahren gemacht, wäre die Redaktion nicht ganz heftig gewesen wie heute, weil heute passt es einfach einfach zur politischen Situation.
Er hat ja dieses Foto sogar vor ein paar Jahren gemacht. Also 2014 gab es genau das gleiche Szenario.
Genau, und damals war es nicht so. Das passt gerade einfach alle zusammen. Aber wie gesagt, wir müssen vom Gas gehen, also das ist auch beidseitig. Das hilft keinem. Was soll denn die Konsequenz sein? Sollen jetzt alle Deutsch-Türken und alle Türken aus dem Land verweisen? Also das will ja auch, ja, bis auf ein paar Extremis vielleicht, will es ja auch keiner. Also das hilft keinem gerade, diese Diskussion auf diesem hohen Level zu führen. Also wir müssen dann die Lösung finden.
Vor allem, es wird dann immer viel von Werten gesprochen und zu dem man sich bekennen müsste, habe ich jetzt auch schon gesagt, also die Werte in Deutschland, Grundgesetz, Meinungsfreiheit und so weiter und so fort. Und es heißt dann immer, man solle sich dazu bekennen, aber das ist halt eine sehr zweischneidige Argumentation. Denn offen gesagt muss man nicht allzu weit recherchieren, um immer wieder zu sehen, dass auch Deutschland sich nicht immer konform zu seinen Werten fällt. Und dass auch Deutschland Rüstungsexporte unterstützt. Dass es in Deutschland genügend Leute gibt, wo ich sagen würde, deren Wertekanon entspricht jetzt aber auch nicht demjenigen, den ich habe und vielleicht auch gar nicht demjenigen, der im Grundgesetz so verankert ist. Ich finde, da hebt man so eine Debatte sehr schnell auf ein Level, wo es schwierig ist, weiter zu argumentieren. Weil plötzlich sitzen alle Argumentierenden in einem Glashaus. Und manche behaupten von sich, ihre Scheiben wären aber aus Plastik, weil sie hätten den einzig richtigen Wertekanon. Das wird sehr, sehr schwierig. Und da habe ich mich dann auch gefragt, welche Dynamik diese Debatte angenommen hat, auch bevor er durch das Verhalten des DFB, auf den ich jetzt gerne dann damit auch mal zu sprechen kommen würde, wenn es da wurde eben gefordert, ja, Mesut Özil und Ilkay Gündoğan müssen sich jetzt zu den Werten des DFB bekennen. Ich möchte jetzt gar nicht die naheliegenden Witze dazu machen, dass sie sich jetzt zu Korruption und Fetternwirtschaft und so weiter bekennen müssen. Aber das geht so ein bisschen in die Richtung, die ich vorhin auch schon gefragt habe, warum soll man sich eigentlich für seine Meinung entschuldigen müssen, müssten wir das nicht aushalten? Und ist es interessantere nicht einfach, ja, welche Konsequenzen man daraus ziehen möchte für die Diskussion rund um Integration, wie gut das funktioniert hat und so weiter? Wie findest du den Umgang denn der Medien mit dieser Debatte? Die haben ja auch wesentlich damit zu tun, dass uns dieses Thema von dem Foto an bis hin zur Weltmeisterschaft und dann auch nach der Weltmeisterschaft beschäftigt hat. Also die Medien haben auch sicherlich zu Recht, es ist das Recht der Medien, ein Thema bei einem Thema nachzuhaken, haben nachgefragt, haben gesagt, wie stehen sie denn? Möchte sich Mesut Özil bitte nicht mal dazu äußern oder auch Ilkay Gündar? Den wollen wir nicht vergessen an dieser Stelle. Und nach der WM war es dann aber so, dass im Gespräch mit Medien der DFB in Person von Reinhard Grindel und Oliver Bierhoff selbst Özil nochmal aus Tapet gehoben hat und aus Tableau gehoben hat. Sind da die Medien zu unkritisch auch mit den beiden umgegangen? Man hätte ja auch in diesen Interviews zum Beispiel, in denen Özil dann ein bisschen schon als Sündenbock dargestellt wurde für die verpatzte WM. Da hat mir die Nachfrage gefehlt. Entschuldigung, aber Sie wollen doch jetzt nicht das WM vor Runden aus an einem Spieler, der offensiv gespielt hat, festmachen. Haben Sie eigentlich die Lücken in der Abwehr gesehen?
Ich tue mich immer ein bisschen schwer, die Medien zu sagen. Ich weiß schon, was du meinst. Ich fand, dass sich viele Kollegen eigentlich eine sehr gute Arbeit gemacht haben. Ich habe auch viele Artikel sehr gerne und sehr gut gelesen. Ich war auch nicht bei weitem mit allen in einer Meinung, aber es war zumindest argumentativ auf einem sehr hohen Niveau. Natürlich gab es auch noch Teile von Medien, die ich heute auch nicht verstehe. Ich habe vorhin gesagt, sie müssen runter vom Gas gehen. Genau die habe ich gemeint. Das Gewicht der Medien in Deutschland und auf der ganzen Welt ist sehr, sehr hoch.
Dann sollten wir jetzt aber vielleicht auch Ross und Reiter benennen. Wenn ich sage, die Medien haben nicht nachgehakt in den Interviews, dann geht es natürlich um ein Weltinterview. Das war das von Oliver Bierhof. Und Reinhard Grindel hat, glaube ich, mit dem Kicker gesprochen. Da hat mir konkret die Nachfrage gefehlt, lag es denn wirklich nur an Özil. Also an dem Punkt, wo die Gesprächspartner Özil aufgebracht haben. Und jetzt im Nachgang zur Debatte kann man sicherlich auch z.B. in Richtung der Springerpässe zeigen, die Art und Weise, wie die Bildzeitung den Rücktritt von Mesut Özil thematisiert. Da kriege ich Gänsehaut im negativen Sinn.
Echt auch. Ich verstehe, ich kenne viele Kollegen, gerade aus dem Sportresort. Ich schätze sie auch sehr, sowohl als Person als auch als Journalisten. Ich kann es nicht nachvollziehen, ehrlich gesagt. Ich finde, die Art und Weise, wie dieses Thema gesagt, ich muss nicht mit dem anderen Meinung sagen, ich muss nicht verstehen, was die Argumente angeht. Ich kann nicht verstehen, die Art und Weise, wie dieses Thema angefallen ist. Man versteht nicht, was man dadurch kaputt macht. Ich weiß nicht, was ist die Intention, was ist der Zweck, warum geht man mit so einer Art und Weise an dieses Thema ran? Weil da steckt so viel dahinter. Wir reden die ganze Zeit über Türken mit deutschen... Deutsche mit der Integration, mit den Türken hier neben. Die sehen das alles, die nehmen das alles wahr. Die werden davon beeinflusst. Man muss vom Garten, das kann nicht funktionieren. Aber zu deiner Frage, ja, genau. Das wurde ich zu wenig hinterfragt. Ich fand, muss ich ehrlich sagen, teilweise perfide, wie man versucht hat, Mesut Özil komplett das in die Schul zu schieben. Das war nicht nur in diesen Interviews, das war auch, finde ich, als Oliver Bioff beim zweiten war. Da fand ich eigentlich, die Atmosphäre war auch viel zu locker. Genau, genau. Das hätte man meiner Meinung nach auch, und die Kollegen, die können das ja auch, noch mal intensiver nachfragen können und auch kritischer nachfragen können. Das ist mir alles so einfach. Vor allem frage ich mich dann, was wäre, wenn diese WM nicht so ausgegangen wäre, wie sie ausgegangen wäre? Hätten wir dann immer noch über Özil gesprochen? Weil das Thema war ja dann vielleicht auch schon, ja zumindest nicht mehr auf diesem Niveau. Das Thema war da, war nicht mehr auf diesem Niveau. Das war dann auch immer abgelutscht. Das ist ja dann eine gewisse Absicht einfach da, dass man sagt, komm, lass uns das Thema jetzt nicht beenden. Lass uns noch mal drüber reden und uns dann aus der Schusslinie nehmen. Also fand ich Wahnsinn. Also von beiden. Ich glaube, es ist ein Wohl von der Bihar auf der Rheinland-Pinsel, dass man Mesut Özil zum Südenbock macht, obwohl man ihn in ihrer Funktion hätte schützen müssen. Also man darf ihn kritisieren, aber man hat ihn da wirklich zum Phras vorgeworfen. Und dann ging es eigentlich erst richtig los. Und ich glaube tatsächlich, es ist immer die Frage, wieso hat Mesut Özil so lange gespügt? Ich glaube, dass jetzt diese Aussagen an Schäfe gewonnen haben, nachdem diese beiden Herren Mesut Özil zum Sückenbock gemacht haben und zum Phras vorgeworfen haben.
Und da finde ich eben, dass man die beteiligten Medien an diesen Interviews dann schon dafür kritisieren kann, dass da nicht nochmal Nachfragen gestellt wurden. Es ist völlig richtig, dass du sagst, es gibt nicht die Medien. Und jetzt im Nachgang gibt es ja auch... Die Argumentation wird so breit geführt, dass du für jedes Mal in meinem Spektrum sehr gute Artikel dafür findest. Aber in diesen konkreten Interviews, in denen es darum ging, ein historisches WM aus aufzuarbeiten, haben meiner Meinung nach die Journalisten nicht die richtige Haltung gezeigt. Und ich kann auch nicht glauben, dass da irgendwelche Fragen rausredigiert wurden, wenn dann der eigentliche Özil-Absatz stehen bleibt, der ja auch noch so häufig gegengelesen wurde beim DFB. Ja, auch so eine Wahnsinnsgeschichte. Aber in diesen Interviews sind auch Fehler gemacht worden, meiner Meinung nach. So, ich habe noch so viele Fragen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir alle hier beantworten können. Aber wenn wir über die Medien sprechen, dann lass uns doch auch nochmal den Umgang mit Reinhard Grindl sprechen. Ist man da vielleicht auch in weiten Teilen der Journalistenlandschaft zu unkritisch mit Reinhard Grindl umgegangen? Denn jetzt im Nachgang tauchen doch einige Zitate auf, als CDU-Abgeordneter auch die Entscheidung getroffen wurde, dass es eine doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft geben würde. Das war Reinhard Grindl dagegen. Er hat auch in mehreren Reden dazu ein Weltbild erkennen lassen, in dem er schon unterscheidet nach Deutschen, die richtige Deutsche sind, in Anführungszeichen, und solche, die irgendwie noch beweisen müssen, dass sie Deutsche sind. Also bei manchen reicht es, dass sie in Deutschland geboren wurden. Und bei anderen, nämlich denjenigen mit einem Migrationshintergrund, die müssen das erst noch irgendwie beweisen. Also dieses Zuwerte-Bekennen hat man schon damals gehört. Das heißt, Reinhard Grindel hat da schon immer eine interessante Sichtweise gezeigt, die vor allem im Kontrast steht zu dem, was er sich als DFB-Präsident dann auf die Fahnen geschrieben hat. Hätte man da nicht vielleicht auch kritischer mit seiner Person umgehen müssen und mit der Art und Weise, wie er sich zu bestimmten Themen geäußert hat, auch vor dieser ganzen Özil-Debatte?
Reinhard Brindl darf gegen die doppelte Staatskultur-Gesellschaft sein. Er darf verlangen, dass Türken mit Migrationshintergrund sich als Beweisen lassen. Er darf Multikulti nicht gut finden, aber dann darf er nicht der DFB-Präsident werden. Also das ist meine Meinung dazu. Weil der DFB hat in den letzten Jahren viel Arbeit geleistet, um die Vielfalt, da gibt es ja auch Spots, die Vielfalt der Nationalmannschaft auszurufen, um diese Integration eben durch den sehr populären Fußball nach Tolle zu bringen. Und ich finde, da wurde auch, ob es jetzt dann an der Oberfläche war oder nicht, aber es wurde viel gemacht. Aber dann darf man so eine Person nicht zum DFB-Präsidenten machen, die alles kaputt gemacht hat. Also wenn ich jetzt Angela Merkel werde, ich würde sagen, Reinhard, was machst du da? Du hast alles kaputt gemacht, was sie in den letzten zehn Jahren aufgebaut haben. Also es ist ein Stadioschritt, das hat der Sofie getan. Der DFB hat es wirklich geschafft. Und dann eine Person von Reinhard Gründl, dass man zehn Jahre Aufbauarbeitintegration wirklich in ein, zwei Wochen komplett kaputt gemacht hat. Ich sehe dann auch schon so, dass Medien durchaus kritischer sein dürfen. Wobei ich da auch, wie gesagt, normal, ich bin ja auch, ich bin einfach Journalist, da muss ich, da bin ich vielleicht ein bisschen vorsichtig. Ich sehe da nicht die Medien, da gibt es auch viele Kollegen, gerade in den sozialen Medien, die da ja auch schon sehr aktiv waren und auch immer noch sind und gutartig sind. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es da zwei Meinungen geben darf. Also ja, zwei Meinungen, ja, okay. Aber das, was Rainer Künzel als Politiker hier sagt hat und jetzt, das stimmt nicht überall, das ist nicht richtig. Und das darf man auch schon hinterfragen. Also wir hinterfragen so viel, wir interpretieren viel, was Mesut Özil macht, also die UK-Gündoern bewegt, aber warum hinterfragen wir nicht Rainer Künzel? Warum sagen wir nicht, wir sagen mal Mesut Özil, du bekennst dich für Deutschland und sagst ja hier, ich bin Deutscher und dann machst du ein Foto mit Erdogan, der Teile der deutschen Nazis nennt. Und warum hinterfragen wir dann nicht Rainer Künzel, der sagt, ja, der Multikulti ist tot und doppelte Staatswirtschaft nein und die Deutschstücken müssen sich erst mal beweisen und jetzt sagst du genau das Gegenteil. Ja, was stimmt? Wann hast du den gelogen? Damals oder heute? Also, man muss das hinterfragen. Also wenn wir auf der ganzen Welt mit dem Finger zeigen, ja schau mal, die haben keine richtige Pressefreiheit, die haben keine Pressefreiheit und da ist keine Meinungsfreiheit, ja, aber dann müssen wir sie doch ausleben. Dann müssen wir doch nur zusammen sagen, so geht das, so funktioniert das und das wird er nicht gemacht. Also nicht von einem gemacht.
Wobei man da vielleicht auch aushalten müsste, wenn Reinhard Grindel eben eine Position hat, die nicht mit der eigenen überdeckt wird. Also mir ist es, ich kann das nachvollziehen, dass du sagst, er darf nicht DFB-Präsident bleiben und ich habe auch eine sehr dezidierte Meinung zu Reinhard Grindel und aus verschiedenen Gründen würde ich auch sagen, der ganze DFB bedarf einiger Reformen. Aber man muss Menschen auch zugestehen, dass sie, Reinhard Grindel hat bestimmt immer gesagt, wenn er auf diese Multikulti-Debatte und seinem damaligen Zitat hingewiesen wurde, Menschen dürfen ihre Meinung auch verändern, aber man muss sie eben an ihren Taten bemessen. Und ich finde hier die Handlungen jetzt im Umgang mit dieser Kauser Özil, wie ich sie nennen würde und Kauser Gündoan ja eigentlich auch, zeigt eben, die Taten passen nicht ganz zu dem, was man gesagt hat. Und das wird jetzt auch thematisiert. Und ich finde, da ist es dann auch in Ordnung, eine Kritik anzuführen, die auch dazu führt, dass man sagt, okay, kann so jemand noch DFB-Präsident bleiben? Aber grundsätzlich muss schon jeder seine Haltung haben dürfen. Es sollte eben nur, finde ich, häufiger thematisiert werden. Also es ist ja sehr gut möglich, dass man, auch wenn Mesut Özil wurde, so oft Nationalspieler des Jahres. Und da gab es genügend Artikel zu. Und da kann man doch in einen Absatz schreiben. Bei Reinhard Grindel hat das und das über ihn gesagt. Das ist interessant, weil er hat das früher mal ganz anders gesehen und zeigt das ja auch, vielleicht zeigt sich die Integration, wie sie funktioniert, auch an einer Person wie Reinhard Grindel. Und dann stellt sich für mich auch die nächste Frage, ich will jetzt gar nicht nur über Bierhoff und Grindel reden, was machen eigentlich die Mitspieler von Mesut Özil gerade? Was macht eigentlich der Mannschaftsrat? Gab es einen Mannschaftsrat? Haben die noch so etwas wie ein Zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl? Da ist jemand zurückgetreten, der 2009 mit großen Teilen der Mannschaft zusammen U21 oder U19, jetzt weiß ich es gerade gar nicht peinlich, den Titel geholt hat. Und wo sind eigentlich die Äußerungen all der angeblich ach so mündigen Nationalspieler?
Also das ist für mich eine der größten Enttäuschungen, ehrlich gesagt. Weil Mesut Özil ist nicht zurückgetreten, weil er sagt, ich möchte mich jetzt auf Arsene konzentrieren, er ist zurückgetreten, weil er sagt, ich fühle mich nicht respektiert und es würde mich rassistisch angegangen. Also das ist, ob wir das jetzt richtig finden oder nicht, das ist harter Tobak. Und sich dann eben, wie du schon sagst, wenn du mal mündige Spieler bist, da gibt es ja einige auch, gar nichts sagen, gar keine Postungen. Die alles posten, aber dann nichts darüber. Dann gibt es für mich daraus zwei Schlussfolge drin. Entweder haben sie Angst oder sie sind Mesut Özil sauer. Also sonst kann ich es nicht erklären, aber es kann schon sein, dass einige von denen es nicht gutheißen, was Mesut gemacht hat, dann macht man auch kein Posting. Aber viel schlimmer für mich ist, wenn die Angst da ist, dass man Angst hat mit Mesut Özil jetzt Schulterschlusszügen. Aber ich habe schon von ein paar Leuten erwartet, dass da was kommt. Jérôme Boateng hat ein Posting gemacht. Aber selbst Jérôme Boateng hat im Rahmen der Euro 2016, wir wissen alle noch, diese Nachbarsdebatte im Gauland, einen riesigen Schulterschluss gehabt. Jeder hat darüber sich beäußert und gesagt, ich jahre mich auch gerne als Nachbarn. Jérôme Boateng macht ein Posting, ja okay, aber als hätte Mesut Özil die Nationalmannschaftskredite einfach so geändert, weil er sich jetzt auf Arsene konzentrieren würde. Kein Boateng-Christmas-Borwurf. Ich schätze Jérôme Boateng auch. Wir hatten ja auch das Interview. Ich bin auch ein guter Typ. Ich hatte von ihm schon erwartet, dass er sich ein bisschen mehr traut. Offenbar ist ja die Angst auch nicht da. Zumindest nicht die Ablehnung da. Und man weiß auch, dass Mesut Özil in der Belandschaft, die eigentlich auch geliebt ist, viele Freunde hat, viel zu wenig und eigentlich gar nichts. Auch da haben wir in Deutschland, glaube ich, auch da ein schlechtes Bild von unserer Zeit. Ich finde es immer ein bisschen schwierig, die Sache mit Jimmy Domas zu vergleichen, weil Jimmy Domas, der schwedische Spieler, der im Kreis was vorgelesen hat, ausgerufen wurde. Es ist schwierig zu vergleichen, weil nicht die gleichen Umstände sind, aber letztlich das Video aus Schweden, das hat die Welt gemacht und alle haben die Schweden applaudiert dafür. Bei uns wurde so ein Spieler für die Welt da draußen, wurde er alle angelassen und das wirft auch kein gutes Licht auf uns Deutsche.
Wenn ich mir etwas wünschen könnte von den Kolleginnen und Kollegen, dann wäre es, dass auf jeder Pressekonferenz, rund um den Bundesliga-Start, wo jemand aus dem Nationalmannschaftsteam sitzt, die Frage gestellt wird, warum haben sie sich überhaupt nicht dazu geäußert und wollen sie es jetzt vielleicht tun? Denn eigentlich ist es, ehrlich gesagt, unfassbar, dass sich dann jemand äußert und wirft ein ganz, ganz schlechtes Licht auf ganz viele Leute, von denen man dachte, sie hätten eine Haltung. Also wir dachten ja eigentlich, wir hätten inzwischen Nationalspiele, die nicht nur bis drei zählen können, sondern auch eine Haltung haben, die sie repräsentieren. Aber in dieser Frage offenbar ja nicht. Nicht genügend Rückgrat und dann darf man da schon die Frage nach den Gründen stellen. Andere Frage, die ich mir gestellt habe, Fatih, warum darf denn Oliver Pocher Witze über die Äußerlichkeiten Mesut Özis machen und gleichzeitig den Fanclub Nationalmannschaft repräsentieren? Wie passt denn das zusammen?
Boah, das ist halt, ja, ich frag mich nicht nur bei Oliver Pocher, sondern auch bei vielen anderen, warum dürfen die überhaupt irgendwas Öffentliches machen? Also das ist so, das ist mir, ja, keine Ahnung. Ich hab ehrlich gesagt, ich hab dazu eine Meinung, aber die ist nicht, nicht zitierfähig. Egal ob Oliver Pocher jetzt Fanclub Nationalmannschaft oder den Cadillac Club anführt, man darf jemanden äußerlich, ja gut, vielleicht darf man es, keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht. Aber man darf es nicht, also ich für meine Werte, man darf es nicht. Und wenn man es macht, soll man es privat machen, aber dann noch einen offiziellen Job bei der DFB, darf man eigentlich nicht machen. Aber ich verstehe auch nicht, wie man diesen Menschen mit einem Mikro an den Mund hält. Was soll das? Das interessiert mich auch alles nicht. Was Oliver Pocher sagt, was auch viele Ex-Fußballer sagen und auch net gesagt haben in den letzten Tagen, Wochen, auch was Uli Hoeneß sagt, das ist schade. Das macht so viel kaputt und das befreut einfach nur weiter die Leute, die das aus einer extremen Warte sehen. Aber ich weiß schon, warum die die Frage stellen. Aber mir ist das zuwider. Also mich nervt das auch.
Es wirft ein schlechtes Licht auf den kompletten Verband.
Ganz extrem.
Was die nächste Frage stellt, wir kommen ein bisschen weg von der Kauser Özil. Aber weil eben aus diesem Foto und aus dem Rücktritt der Vorwurf des Rassismus offen wurde, den Özil aufgebracht hat, wo auch viele Leute gesagt haben, was hat denn das mit Rassismus zu tun, wo ich jetzt erstmal die Haltung vertreten würde, so viel Haltung gestehe ich mir jetzt hier in diesem Podcast zu, dass ich sagen würde, also wenn jemand selbst sagt, er würde rassistisch beleidigt, dann steht das jetzt erstmal anderen Leuten nicht zu, das nicht anzuerkennen, sondern da muss man dann schon erstmal bitte diesen Vorwurf nachgehen. Und ehrlich gesagt ist das auch eine Internetrecherche von 0,03 Sekunden, dass du rassistische Beleidigungen über Mesut Özil lesen kannst im Internet. Also das muss jemandem schon zugestanden sein, dass er dann auch die Rassismus, jetzt hätte ich fast gesagt die Karte spielt, das ist natürlich Quatsch, aber dass er Rassismus als Rassismus benennt, das muss jedem erstmal zugestehen. Aber dann sind wir ja auch... Dann haben wir eben diesen Verband und die Art und Weise, wie er sich nicht dazu äußert. Die Mitspieler nicht, der Mannschaftsrat nicht, der über DFB-Präsident und Sportdirektor haben wir schon kurz zumindest gesprochen, sehr, sehr schwierig. Und das führt mich dann eigentlich zu einer anderen Frage, die ich auch ganz gerne in dem Zusammenhang jetzt mal diskutiert hätte, was aber gerade nicht stattfindet. Was tut denn eigentlich der DFB gegen rechtsgerichtete Fans? Denn die hat der DFB. Wir hatten Vorkommnisse beim Auswärtsspiel in Prag. Übrigens konnte niemand von denen identifiziert werden. Ist auch so ein bisschen in der Medienlandschaft untergegangen. Trotz aller hochauflösenden Bilder, die man von den Leuten da hatte, konnte niemand tatsächlich nachgewiesen werden. Er hätte da sich an den rechtsradikalen Parolen geäußert. Was tut der DFB gegen rechte Fans? Denn wenn Mesut Özil zum Beispiel in seinem Statement selbst schreibt, er sei rassistisch beleidigt worden nach einem Spiel der deutschen Nationalmannschaft, dann ist das doch eine absolut virulente und wichtige Frage.
Es kann sein, dass der DFB keine Zeit hat, gegen Rechte was zu tun hat. Man muss ja Hashtags erfütten und man muss tolle Teamhotels raussuchen. Da bleibt dann keine Zeit, um mit rechten Fans in der Sicht zu bewegen.
Jetzt habe ich den Chefredakteur von Sokrates in die Problemik getrieben.
Soweit ist es gekommen, Fatih.
Du musst mir die Frage jetzt auch nicht beantworten. Aber warum wird diese Frage nicht gestellt? Es wirkt doch so, dass es da blinde Flecken fast gibt. Und während über alle anderen Dinge sich viele orten, also lass jemand eine Pyro-Fackel anzünden im Stadion. Und du wirst sofort 100 Haltungen dazu lesen, in denen es heißt, das ist kein Fußball, das sind sogenannte Fußballfans, das macht den Fußball kaputt. Und ich will jetzt nicht die Pyro-Debatte verharmlosen oder rechtfertigen oder so weiter. Aber warum ist das denn bei solchen Dingen nicht genauso? Und wenn ich lese, ein deutscher Fan hat einen deutschen Nationalspieler rassistisch beleidigt. Und es gibt, wenn ich mir gleichzeitig umgucke und ich nicht glaube, dass das komplett an den Haaren herbeigezogen ist, das kann ich mir sehr, sehr gut vorstellen, wenn ich die aktuelle Debatte verfolge, dann muss doch die Frage gestellt werden, was kann man denn gegen solche Ressentiments tun, wenn sie auch im Fußballumfeld aufkommen? Denn das passt doch auch nicht zu den ach so tollen deutschen Werten.
Max, man muss es wollen. Ich glaube, wenn man will, dass man dieses Thema zu bekämpfen, dann kriegt man das auch hin. Wir leben in einer Zeitalter, in der Technik man so viel erlaubt, mit auflesenden Kameras, mit allem, worum man dann, und Gottes Willen, ich bin auch nicht dafür, dass man jetzt jeden einzelnen Fan beobachten muss, aber sowas kann man relativ schnell rausfinden. Und wenn man das Thema lösen will, man kann es lösen. Ich möchte dem DFB nicht absprechen, dass man, also nicht mal jetzt runterschwellig, ich glaube nicht, dass der DFB sich freut, wenn ein paar Rechte da auf den Rechten auf den Längen setzen und Spieler beleidigen. Ich glaube, das wollen sie definitiv nicht. Warum sollen sie das wollen?
Nein, glaube ich auch nicht. Wollte ich damit auch nicht unterstellen.
Nein, nein, ich weiß, ich weiß. Aber ich verstehe diese Ignoranz dann nicht. Das ist ja ein offensichtliches Problem. Das Problem hat ja auch nicht nur Mesut Özil. Mesut Özil ist heute weg. Jetzt ist NK Günder noch da. Es ist Emre Can noch da. In den U-Mannschaften sind viele Türken, da kommen alle hoch. Es sind auch nicht nur die Deutsch-Türken, es gibt ja noch ein paar andere auch. Das müsste Punkt eins sein auf der Agenda. Weil es ist immer noch so. Es ist schlimm genug, was wir hier leben. Aber es gibt noch eine Welt da draußen, die gerade sehr genau schaut, was die Deutschen gerade machen. Mesut Özil hat sich auf Englisch geäußert. Er ist dadurch aufmerksam stark geworden. Man hat gesehen, wer sich alles dazu geäußert hat. Arsenal hat sich hinter Mesut gestellt. Viele Berühmtheiten, viele Meinungsmacher haben sich hinter Özil gestellt. Da stehen die Deutschen gerade in der Kritik. Ganz extrem. Nicht nur in der Türkei, ganz und gar nicht. Es ist auf der ganzen Welt. Und jetzt ist der DFB und Deutschland gefordert, Maßnahmen zu treffen. Keine Visi-Vasi-Maßnahmen, sondern wirklich Maßnahmen, die effektiv sind, um dieses anscheinend vorhandene Ressismusproblem entscheidend gegenüberzutreten. Das muss jetzt gemacht werden. Da gibt es gar keine Alternative. Wenn bisher nichts gemacht wurde, dann muss sich der DFB zusammensetzen und eine Lösung finden. Ich habe kein Sicherheitsexperte, das ich sagen kann, dass soll gemacht werden. Ich bin auch nicht dafür. Ich kenne es außer der Türkei. In der Türkei gab es viele Jahre große Probleme. Auf den längeren Stadien mit der Gewalt. Das wurde irgendwann mit elektronischen Tickets gelöst. Deutlich viel sicher geworden, deutlich weniger Sachen. Aber ich bin nicht dafür. Das ist mir eine Spur zu heftig. Aber ich glaube schon, dass man so etwas kontrollieren kann. Man kann da entscheidend gegen übertreten. So viel Macht, so viel Einfluss hat der DFB dann schon.
Es soll nicht falsch verstanden werden. Auch an der Stelle darf jeder Mensch seine Meinung haben. Und Leute dürfen Mesut Özil auch doof finden. Sie dürfen ihn auch aufgrund seiner Herkunft doof finden. Aber Artikel 1 gut gesetzt. Die Würde des Menschen ist unenthassbar. Sie zu achten und zu schützen, ist die Verpflichtung aller staatlichen Gewalten. Und nicht nur der staatlichen Gewalten, sondern auch der Gesellschaft. Es gibt Grenzen, die dürfen im Zusammenleben nicht übertreten werden. Dazu gehört dann zum Beispiel eine rassistische Beleidigung. Das ist keine Meinungsäußerung mehr, die vom Grundgesetz gedeckt ist. Und da muss man dann eben etwas tun. Ich bin jetzt fast froh, dass du auch gesagt hast, du weißt jetzt auch gar nicht, was man da machen würde. Das ist ja das Schwierige an dieser Debatte. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass wir eine Fan-ID einführen und dann haben wir keine Ressentiments mehr unter Fußballerhängern. Die Debatte ist größer als der Fußball und wird jetzt aber anhand des Fußballs gerade ins Rampenlicht gezogen. Mir fehlt da eben schon die Diskussion darüber. Da ist Rassismus ein großes Wort. Wenn du über Ressentiments sprichst, kannst du darüber fast schon nicht mehr unaufgeregt sprechen. Denn da fühlen sich viele Leute sofort angegriffen. Oder es fängt auch sehr früh so ein What-about-ism an. Also was ist denn eigentlich mit denen? Ja, aber es gibt ja auch linksradikale Straftaten. Und es gibt auch das. Und hast du nicht auch hier das gesagt? Also da wird sehr schnell mit dem Finger gezeigt und man lenkt es von der eigentlichen Debatte weg. Aber das ist doch eigentlich der Kern, um den es hier gehen sollte. Und wir haben begonnen bei einem Foto mit einem türkischen Staatspräsidenten, wie auch immer wir den finden wollen. Und jetzt sind wir gelandet bei einer Debatte rund um das Thema. Haben wir in Deutschland einen Rückschritt gemacht, was dem angeht, wie wir Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund begegnen? Oder ist es vielleicht gar kein Rückschritt, sondern es sind nur Ressentiments, die jetzt deutlicher sichtbar geworden sind, die es vielleicht schon immer gab? Und vielleicht ist das die eigentliche Debatte, die geführt werden muss. Und sicherlich ist deswegen dieses Thema so groß.
Es ist definitiv ein Rückschritt da. Ich habe vorhin gesagt, dass es da durchaus eine Entwicklung gab in den letzten Jahren in die richtige Richtung. Aber wir sind an einem Punkt angelangt, in dem unser Innenminister abgeschobene Flüchtlinge zählt. Und abgeschobene Menschen zählt, in der wir ernsthaft darüber sprechen, ob man Menschen enttricken lässt oder nicht. Das zeigt alles gerade, dass, okay, Meinungsausführungen, ja, soll, darf man. Aber das sind für mich keine Themen, über die man sprechen darf. Also diese Flüchtlingsdebatte hat etwas aufgewühlt. Ich weiß nicht, was es ist. Es hat irgendwas aufgefühlt. Es hat auch teilweise Mut, den Menschen Mut gemacht, noch klarer vielleicht jede versteckte Meinung zu machen. Vielleicht haben wir uns gar nicht entwickelt, sondern haben einfach alle jede Meinung versteckt. Und auf einmal haben alle den Mut, sich so zu äußern, wie sie es gerade tun. Also der Rückschritt ist da, definitiv. Es zeigt nicht nur der Fall Mesut Özil gerade, es zeigt einige Probleme, über die wir reden. Es zeigt die Menschen gerade, die im Bundestag sitzen, in den verschiedenen Landtagen sitzen. Ich unterstelle nicht jede Menschen, der AfD wählt, dass er komplett recht eingestellt ist. Da ist irgendwas passiert in den letzten Monaten, Jahren, dass sich so eine Bewegung eingesetzt hat. Vielleicht ist es auch nicht nur ein Deutschlandproblem, sondern das zieht sich ja gerade durch die ganze Welt. Ich glaube, an dem Punkt bin ich jetzt tatsächlich, dass ich jetzt sage, das ist auch kein großes Problem. Es passiert gar nichts in der Welt. Wir haben das große Pech, dass wir in dieser Welle gerade mittendrin sitzen. Ich weiß, aber ich habe auch eine äußere Befürchtung, dass das nicht so leicht aufzuhalten ist. Es wird immer mehr, es wird nicht weniger. Aber wir haben in Deutschland einfach auch aufgrund unserer Vielfalt, die hier da ist, und den vielleicht dann gegenzutreten. Aber da muss ja auch jemand mal anfangen. Es hilft einfach nicht, das jetzt noch weiter zu befreuen. Deswegen habe ich auch vorhin gesagt, wir müssen vom Gas gehen. Das hilft für alle. Wir müssen irgendwo einen U-Plan zu ziehen.
Ja, in Kaufbeuren wurde jetzt der Neubau einer Moschee nach Bürgerentscheid abgelehnt. Es ist jetzt nur ein kleines Detail, es ist auch ein bisschen untergegangen, aber so weit ist es, dass die Angst vor anderen, vor dem Fremden, vor Religionen so groß ist, dass man sie nicht mehr ausüben lässt.
So, und an dem Punkt sagen dann viele Deutsch-Türken, was wäre, wenn in Ankara der Bau einer Kirche abgelehnt worden wäre? Wie wäre das angekommen? Also nur, um mal eine Einschätzung zu geben, wie die Menschen denken.
Genau, und eigentlich sind wir dann aber auch schon bei dem gelandet, was diese Debatten so schwierig macht, nämlich Fingerpointing. Und dann geht es eigentlich gar nicht mehr um die Sache. Und die eigentliche Sache ist doch, wenn wir über Werte sprechen, zu denen man sich bekennen muss, als DFB, als Deutsche, als Gesellschaft, dann muss man die Werte erleben. Und dazu gehören viele Dinge, die in dieser Debatte nicht gemacht werden. Und dieses Aufgeregte in dieser Debatte hat ganz viel damit zu tun, dass die Leute in einem Wertekanon sich befinden und den verteidigen mit Mann und Maus. Und dieser Wertekanon aber offensichtliche Lücken hat, weil eben Dinge passieren, wie eben das im Mittelmeer Flüchtlinge ertrinken und da dann doch eine nicht unterschätzende Zahl der Deutschen sagt, ja, recht so. Wir haben Videos, wo Leute absaufen, skandieren in Deutschland. Und wir haben das auch genügend. Auf der anderen Seite des politischen Spektrums haben wir auch Meinungen, die sich nicht mit den Werten decken. Und das, glaube ich, ist die Ursache, warum diese Diskussionen auch so schnell an Schärfe gewinnen und warum sie so schnell so verstrickt werden. Also ich habe den Eindruck, in dieser ganzen Debatte geht es weder nach vorne noch nach hinten. Und ich hatte angefangen diese Sendung, indem ich gesagt habe, wir wollen so ein bisschen Impulse geben, ein paar Fragen stellen, die sonst wenig gestellt werden und nicht das große Ganze besprechen. Und wir sind doch selbst wieder beim Großen und Ganzen gelandet, Fatih. Wir haben eigentlich gar nicht das eingehalten, was wir uns vorgenommen hatten. Ich habe jetzt auch einige meiner Fragen gar nicht gestellt. Aber vielleicht ist das auch, ich glaube, das steht für die Debatte. Du kannst, es geht, wie gesagt, es ging los mit einem einfachen Foto eines Nationalspielers. Und jetzt steht hier der Max in seinem Aufnahmestudio und erzählt was von Werten und für die man eintreten muss und fühlt sich auf einmal, als wäre er Pfarrer. Ohne jetzt, dass ich gerade eine Religion predigen würde, sondern Pfarrer des Grundgesetzes. Vielleicht ist es sinnbildlich für die ganze Debatte und warum sie so geführt wird, wie sie gerade geführt wird.
Ja, es ist so. Ich glaube, man kommt gar nicht drum herum, wenn man über Özil spricht, dann man das Ganze ganz und sehen. Ich finde es auch gut, weil ich finde, jetzt ist auch eine Chance da. Wir sagen, es muss etwas gemacht werden. Wir wissen zwar nicht was, aber es muss etwas gemacht werden. Ich glaube, das ist jetzt schon eine Gelegenheit, zu sagen, so jetzt, jetzt kommen wir nicht mehr drum herum. Jetzt ist der Vorwurf da. Der Vorwurf ist nicht nur von einer Person, sondern sie wächst. Sie begriff viele, viele Menschen, die in diesem Land leben. Das sind auch nicht nur Menschen, die Integrationsuntergrund haben, sondern auch viele Menschen, die keine Integrationsuntergrund haben, fühlen ja diese Probleme. Und jetzt ist einfach auch eine Chance da, zu sagen, so, jetzt machen wir mal was und wir machen jetzt wirklich etwas, was auch vielleicht einen gewissen Effekt hat. Und zwar, dass sich die Menschen wieder zueinander finden, dass man diese Schärfe herausnimmt, dass Integration wirklich wieder nicht durch einseitig im Einpeitschen geschieht, sondern dass man da den Dialog sucht, weil so eine Integration kannst du nicht einseitig machen. Du musst dem Menschen das Gefühl geben, dass du sie auch integrieren willst und nicht hier dulden willst. Und wenn du das schaffst, kommen wir auch wieder auf ein Level, das erhältlich ist. Dazu muss man auch sagen, und das ist immer so in Gesprächen, dass man dann versucht, so ein Happy End zu finden. Es gibt dann auch genug Menschen in diesem Land, die auf beiden Seiten, die es schaffen, nebeneinander zu leben und sich nicht gegenseitig Scheiße zu finden. Zum Glück ist es ja auch die Mehrzahl und Mehrheit. Und ich, als jemand, der Mesut Özil nachhelfen kann, fühle mich nach wie vor sehr, sehr wohl. Ich habe mich nicht integriert. Ich bin ein Teil der Gesellschaft, ich muss mich nicht integrieren. Und das fühle ich mich nach wie vor. Und ich werde auch meinen Beitrag dazu leisten, dass es auch anderen so geht, das, was ich kann. Ich habe jetzt nicht die Macht, und ich möchte ja auch nicht haben, jeden da mit dran zu ziehen, aber das, was ich kann, das tue ich. Und das ist, glaube ich, die Aufgabe von uns allen.
Ich glaube, das ist ein schönes Schlusswort. Ich hoffe, dass wir mit dieser Sendung Fatih etwas beigetragen haben zur Debatte, bei der viele Hörerinnen und Hörer sagen, das hat sie jetzt doch bereichert und war dann nicht der Beitrag Nummer XY mit den immer gleichen Argumenten. Ich bin gespannt, wie die Diskussion weiterläuft. Ich würde mir bei allem wünschen, was jetzt auch wahrscheinlich im Forum zu dieser Folge diskutiert wird, auf YouTube, in den sozialen Netzwerken, Menschlichkeit. Ach, ich war heute mit großen Worten um mich herum. Aber zur Menschlichkeit gehört eine Form des Umgangs. Und auch Leute, es wird viele Leute geben, die mit vielem nicht übereinstimmen, was auch ich hier gesagt habe, die das kritisieren werden. Und es wird vielleicht auch Leute geben, die übereinstimmen mit Dingen, die wir sagen. Aber der Ton macht da die Musik. Und bitte lasst uns ordentlich miteinander diskutieren, auch wenn wir unterschiedliche Meinungen haben. Ich erträge dieses Rumgeschrei nicht mehr. Und ich habe auch schon selbst E-Mails bekommen, wo ich mir gedacht habe, wo lebe ich ja eigentlich? Bitte lasst uns in einer vernünftigen Art und Weise weiter reden. Und dir, Fatih, danke ich, dass du mit mir hier geredet hast. Der längste Kurzpass aller Zeiten, ich verpasse meinen Anschlusstermin. Aber es ging jetzt nicht kürzer. Und trotzdem haben wir noch nicht mal alle Dinge abgehandelt. Aber vielen, vielen Dank, Fatih, dass du dir Zeit genommen hast für diesen Kurzpass.
Sehr gerne. Max auch vielen Dank für die Sendung. Ich fand auch, dass die Länge es verdient hat. Und ja, lass uns positiv sein, dass das auch alles wieder in die richtige Richtung geht.
Man kann dir auf Twitter folgen. Das ist ein deutschsprachiger Count. Soweit ist es nämlich gekommen. Der Fatih twittert zweisprachig. Unglaublich. Es ist unglaublich. Vielen Dank, Fatih Demireli, Chefredakteur vom Sokrates Sportmagazin. Dem denkenden Sportmagazin sei an dieser Stelle auch sehr empfohlen. Und man hat, glaube ich, auch einen Eindruck bekommen, was das bedeutet, wenn man denkt und wenn man einen weiten Horizont hat und dann auch mal auf Fragen nicht nur mit Ja oder Nein antwortet, weil der Horizont soweit ist. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Ich hoffe, die Folge ist auf euer Gehör nicht nur gestoßen, sondern auch auf gefallen. Lasst uns die Diskussion sinnvoll weiterführen. Ich bin gespannt, freue mich drauf. Bis bald, macht's gut.